وبما اننا نتحدث عن المعلم من رام الله
ينضم لنا الاستاذ الجامعي غسان الخطيب
والساتي جامعه بيرزيت وهو استاذ نادين
خماش اهلا بك يا دكتور احنا فجعناها
للنادينا على فكره مش عارفه انك موجود
معانا واو
اهلا بكم
طيب دكتور احنا جبناك خصوصي لنعرف مفاجاه
حلوه صباح الخير
والله انا يعني اشعر بالفخر واعتزاز عندما
اشاهد نديم خماش في عملها وهي ناجحه بكل
المقاييس
واتذكر الفتره التي كانت فيها طالبه وتذكر
انها تركت لدي انطباع بانها طالبه واعده
فقد كانت
تلميذه جاده جدا ومجتهده
ولديها حب استطلاع كبير وايضا كان لديها
قدره على توجيه الاسئله الصعبه همم هذا
جزء من ما اتذكر عنها وانك استاذ اشعر
بفخر شديد عندما اشاهد تلاميذي ناجحين
وموفقين في الحياه ونادين هي نموذج همم من
هذه ان نماذج وهذا هو يعني المردود
الاساسي والاهم همم لاي استاذ بغض النظر
اذا كان استاذ جامعي او استاذ مدرسي او
غير ذلك
دكتور واترك الطالبه تحاور دكتوره يعني
انا اعجز عن التعبير وانا فعلا سعيده
وفعلا تفاجات بهذه المفاجاه انت فخر لنا
استاذ غسان الخطيب وفخر لفلسطين وفخر لكل
الطلبه الذين تتلمذوا على يدك ونتحدث كمان
انه نشير بالذكر انه الاستاذ غسان كان
عامل وزير في الاعلام في فلسطين وبالتالي
يعني نحن فخرون بان تكون ضيفنا اليوم في
برنامج صباح العربيه اضافه كبيره في
حياتنا في مسيرتنا التعليميه في جامعه
بيرزيت وايضا اضافه كبيره لنا لتكون على
الهواء مباشره في برنامج صباح العربيه
شكرا لكم وشكرا اليكم ولي يا زميلاتك
وزملائك الحقيقه يعني مجرد افراد حلقه
لموضوع التعليم هو بحد ذاته امر في غايه
الاهميه لانه بعد هذه التجارب الطويله
اييه نعتقد بانه من بين متطلبات نهوض
الامم المختلفه والعديده اعتقد بان
التعليم هو المتطلب الاول لانه التعليم هو
الذي يؤدي الى مجتمع ذو ثقافه
متطوره وهو ايضا المجتمع الذي يهيء
الاقتصاد متطور فالاقتصاد الحديث الان
يسمى اقتصاد المعرفه اللي هو ناتج عن
التقدم العلمي والبحثي ولذلك يعني نهوض
وتطور الامم مرتبط بالاهتمام بالعمليه
التعليميه فشكرا لاهتمامكم
ما الذي ينقص اليوم العمليه التعليميه
للمضي بها قدما اكثر فاكثر خصوصا مع
التغيرات في الحالي
الحقيقه انه كل الدراسات في هذا المجال
التي تتعلق بالتنميه التنميه المجتمعيه
بشكل عام تشير الى علاقه وارتباط بين نجاح
العمليه التنمويه وبين التركيز والاستثمار
في العمليه التعليميه
وهذا امر يعني يخلق نوع من عدم الارتياح
عندما نقارن بين ما يستثمر في المنطقه
العربيه في العمليه التعليميه مقابل ما
يستثمر في دول اخرى التي نهضت وتطورت
لاسباب عديده من ضمنها الاهتمام والتركيز
على العمليه التعليميه والبحث العلمي لذلك
هذه مناسبه لدعوه جميع من لهم علاقه
باتحاد القرار في المجتمعات العربيه
بالتركيز على اولويه التعليم من الناحيه
الكميه ومن الناحيه النوعيه
التوجهات تروح مثلا بدهم يكونوا اطباء حتى
الاهل كانوا حابين انه اولادهم يكونوا
اطباء او مهندسين دائما اكثر همم تخصص كان
هل اليوم اختلفت التخصصات اختلفت التوجهات
باختلاف الظروف التي طرات علينا بفعل
التكنولوجيا وكل هذه الامور
نعم يعني في كل مرحله تختلف الاولويات همم
صحيح انه ما زالت مهنه الطب يعني هي من
المهن همم الاكثر جاذبيه ولكن الى جانب
ذلك الان نلاحظ مثلا اهتمام شديد في
الاقبال على المهن التي لها علاقه بصناعه
المعلومات والتقنيات الحديثه والاي تي
والقضايا المتعلقه بالتطور التقني
والكمبيوتر
والمعلوماتيه همم مثلا همم كليات الاي تي
مثلا همم في جامعه بيرزيت على سبيل المثال
هي التي عليها اكبر طلب مقارنه بالكليات
الاخرى الكليات المهنيه تاتي بالدرجه
الثانيه وللاسف هناك تراجع في الاقبال على
بعض
الاختصاصات المهمه مثل الاختصاصات العلميه
الفيزيائيه الكيمياء الرياضيات
والتربيه وما الى ذلك ولذلك الحكومات
والجامعات عليها ان تبذل الجهد لاحداث
توازن لانه المجتمع يحتاج جميع هذه
التخصصات وجميع هؤلاء الخريجين
السوشيال ميديا التي بدات تاخذ شيئا فشيئا
وتزيح نوعا ما الاعلام التقليدي انصح
التسميه
اعتقد بانه
الاعلام
كاختصاص اكاديمي بدا يتاقلم مع المعطيات
الجديده همم سابقا الاعلام من ناحيه
التدريس همم كان بعيدا عن التفاعل مع
متطلبات التواصل
انه الجامعات المختلفه
انا اسمعكم جيدا
كنت احاول ان اقول بانه الجامعات مؤخرا
ودوائر واقسام الاعلام بدات يعني تتاقلم
مع التطور الاخير الذي جعل من وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هي اداء اساسيه
وبالتالي لاحظنا بانه هناك نوع من التزاوج
والتفاعل والتكامل بين همم اسس المهن
الاعلاميه
والاداء والوسائل الخاصه بالتواصل
الاجتماعي وبالتالي الانتاج الاعلامي بدا
يقدم بشكل تدريجي
واساليب التواصل الاجتماعي وهذا ما بدا
يتم التهيئه له والاعداد له في كليات
الاعلام في الجامعه
بانني محظوظه بان اكون محاطه بين
اساتذه من ال الخطيب استاذ غسان في جامعه
بيرزيت وايضا دكتور نبيل الخطيب الذي ما
في حياتنا المهنيه بعد ذلك يعني وكان احد
مدراء قناه العربيه وتتلمدنا ايضا على يده
في المجال المهني وكنا معك في المجال
الاكاديمي استاذ غسان خطيب استاذ في جامعه
بيرزيت شكرا لك على وجودك